live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships the phone number to
jump in is
8825 5225 that's
8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman thrilled to be
joined by George camel with a K and we
are here for you this our George is our
resident money expert today I'll help
you in areas of work that is very much
tied to your money when we're talking
about incomes if you're feeling stuck
confused burned out overlooked and
you're a little bit worried about
whether or not you can make a
professional move while in the baby
steps I assure you you can and I'm here
to help on those questions we team up on
all of it George you ready to go we have
a good time Ken always a good Friday
when I'm it's always good to see what
you're wearing today I like that you've
got a uh an ensemble here I'm going for
the fall uh you know the ainal Wardrobe
you look like youve stepped out of a J
crew hat I was going for more of a Tim
the Tool Man Taylor but I'll take J crew
yeah I don't think you will ever achieve
Tim the toolman Taylor I can turn the
wrench if need be yes so can I but just
in the air I can turn a wrench around
that's all I can that's where we're
served best George and I stay away from
the tools but we can help you and by the
way before we get to the phones I want
to acknowledge a fabulous crowd out in
the studio live studio audience in the
lobby of Sol have people to look at they
yeah we're very excited sometimes when
it's empty we get depressed but these
people out there fabulous looking they
look very excited to be here uh we know
they're disappointed that Dave isn't but
they're pressing through they're
pressing through so that's your tagline
press on press on so thank you very much
let's go Triple 8 825 5225 Tim joins us
in the windy city Chicago Illinois Tim
how can we
help hey guys how you doing today we're
having a blast what's up hey so so just
uh I guess a two-part question so um
looking at a potential layoff at my
place of employment so they came in and
reduce the workforce by roughly 30% to
my surprise I was not one I was fully
expecting to be one let go um but I
wasn't and I've been assured that
there's no more cups coming so my
question is you know what could I do to
prepare myself financially in the event
that that comes you know do I start
seeking other employment you know I make
a generous salary so do I write it out
um what should let's jump in let's jump
in there so had had there not been
company layoffs would you be asking me
the question about looking at someplace
else so potential I mean I've always
explored other opportunities um but
never really Thor you know thoroughly
gone through with anything but you know
I was kind of actively looking but I
guess I was at one foot in one foot out
okay well since you were actively
looking I would continue to look that
doesn't mean you have to leave
and we actually don't teach that you
leap anyway if we're talking about
really leaping to something or just kind
of well I'm going to leave and then I'm
going to go find something so if you
were already looking Tim I would
continue to look there were reasons why
you were looking I'd continue to look
but I wouldn't be looking out of fear I
would be looking towards my future you
know what where do I want to be in 5
years 10 years 15 years down the line
that needs to be the dominant question
here because you're not truly happy
fulfilled or you wouldn't be looking is
that fair yeah that's a fair statement I
mean my my end goal is I want to you
know somewhat part-time go part-time
around 50 you know we've my myself and
my wife we've worked extremely hard to
clear our debts so you know we don't
have much overhead debt you know I do
some freelance real estate stuff I try
and flip a house a year I just got my
first rental this year um but with that
said I also have that flexibility with
my current job whereas I'm afraid if I
jump somewhere else that flexibility
will be gone something to think about
and you know one thing I would mention
too instead of just flipping all the
time cuz flipping requires a purchase
there's risk there if you've got your
real estate license I don't know if you
do but if you do and you've got work
flexibility you know I'd be trying to
sell five to 10 houses a year or let's
set a goal for three houses and we put
that money aside that's why I want to
bring George in you know I I I give
people advice to always have some extra
income some side income is good I think
he's got that with the real estate play
but just from a planning standpoint you
know we shouldn't be walking around
George expecting to get laid off all the
time but we should have a plan where do
you fall on a 3 to six-month emergency
fund uh versus being used for major
emergencies versus a layoff because I
would tell people get back to work as
quick as possible what what are your
what's your advice financially how do we
prepare financially not just
professionally for sure well one is
getting out of debt and it sounds like
Tim you don't have any Consumer Debt
right now so we have One auto loan which
is my pickup truck and then uh our
primary home that we live in and then my
rental property and that's literally it
okay so the auto loan needs to be your
priority right now if you're truly
worried about this layoff happening I
want no debt in my life I want to owe
less people money so that I can float by
longer if I need to use that emergency
fund I'm guessing you don't have an
emergency fund then yeah I'm sitting on
a little bit of cash um which is you
know I was planning on using towards our
next property purchase so I'd say
probably right around 15,000 in cash and
what's left on the auto loan uh probably
33 what do you guys
make uh so my wife she she just started
doing some work so she's knocking down
maybe four 500 bucks a week and I'm
probably I think this year I'll probably
do 115,000 in my primary source of
income okay awesome so you got a a great
income there but I want to see this
autol loan debt cleaned up so I'm going
to use the majority of that cash to
clean up this debt that'll leave you
with about half of the auto loan and the
next few months if you're truly worried
I would want no debt and so that would
be my next goal is to get rid of the
auto loan and then restock the emergency
fund up to 3 to six months of expenses
I'd probably lean towards 6 months if
this is going to be looming in your
future I would just stack up as much
cash as I could and once things
stabilize we'll know more we'll start
investing but it sounds like you're
doing a lot at once you're trying to pay
off some debt you're trying to save
you're probably doing some investing
right now you're buying property and
flipping it is that
Fair yeah that's 100% accurate is the
rental income that you mentioned to
George or the rental debt is that the
next Flip or is it something you're
holding on to no this one I'm going to
hold I think uh as we you know the the
first flip I did last year is what
helped me purchase this one plus tuck my
money back in my pocket um and we were
you know we were getting top top dollar
for the houses that were flipping versus
the purchase price so that the RO the
ROI was really good but
um I mean I definitely want to get more
into rentals as that you know pass
long-term passive income you know keeps
what are you how are you financing these
flips
currently just a 30-year mortgage with
the current rates and then you're trying
to get rid of them
fast yeah uh it's at a seven I think
it's seven and a half% interest on that
one I would if I'm in your shoes I'm
slowing down on this flipping business
and I'm going to get my financial house
in order I'm going to let this this
layoff scenario just be a good wakeup
call to go hey let's get completely out
of debt let's have an emergency fund
let's be investing for the future and
then future flips I would encourage you
to pay cash which is controversial in
the real estate investing world but man
it's a different ball game and you do
with a whole lot more peace and a whole
lot more
profit oh absolutely no if I had that
kind of capital to go in and offer cash
that's cost us a lot of properties too
because we don't have that cash flow
built up well you know what to do man I
hope you do it but I'm going to push
pause and take a look in the financial
mirror before I continue the the
flipping game sounds like you're great
at it but when you start start doing
with cash and no debt and you have that
stable income it's going to be a whole
different ball game you want to get
yourself to a point folks where you are
layoff proof and you can do that if you
follow the financial principles that we
teach you can get to a place where hey
it still sucks to get laid off but
you're not freaking out all right good
stuff George camel Ken Coleman with you
America this is the ramsy show don't
move more coming
[Music]
up
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for yours business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
thrill that you are with us
8825 5225
8825 5225 is the number to jump in I'm
Ken Coleman George camel joins me we're
here to answer your questions I'll take
any work related questions as it relates
to your income uh maybe even your
stress uh the anxiety at work any of
that stuff we'll talk about your work
we'll talk about your money George is
here for your money questions and we're
thrilled that all of you have joined us
today Cara is up in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania how can we
help hi um thanks for taking my call you
bet um yeah uh so I'm new to Dave Ramsey
by like five days wow that's awesome
welcome yeah so thank you yeah I'm
excited um and terrified so I have um I
have a master's degree that I've been
working on for uh three years and I only
have three credits left um and I uh
obviously am not going to borrow money
to finish it but I'd like to finish in
the spring um so I have a IRA a SE Ira
from a previous employer
um and that business has since closed I
don't work there and there's nothing
being contributed to it at this point um
but it has about $5,000 and it would
cover the tuition to finish my
Master's so I'm just
wondering um what your thoughts are on
should I should I cash out the IRA and
pay for school that way or should I just
um kind of put off graduating and keep
working and saving and yeah so that's my
what I'm asking well it's a great
question and uh since you're new to the
program first of all welcome and second
of all if you if you keep listening to
the show you'll probably hear us say
don't Rob yourself of your retirement
and there's a few reasons for that
number one if you cash out from the SEP
IRA you're going to miss out on all the
future compound growth and if you want
to know what I'm talking about you can
go punch that into our investment
calculator and put in you know how much
money's in there right
now uh 5,000 okay so if you put in
$5,000 and you just didn't touch it for
the next 20 years you would realize why
it would be a mistake to cash that out
number two you're going to pay penalties
because you're not at the age where you
can withdraw it without tax penalties so
it's going to count as income you'll get
hit with a tax penalty on top of that
and for that reason I'm going to say
let's pause let's not touch that account
and let's cash flow the rest of your
schooling with future income and number
three Cara $5,000 isn't enough you can
you can generate $5,000 so how much do
you need to come up with to finish this
Masters um so it's 18 uh how much cash
um yeah because you're not gonna take a
loan right and I I'd rather not dip into
what um I've saved for my baby steps um
so um I let's see if I I don't think
well so I have the $1,000 for Stu one
and then I have 2,000 I have 2,000
additionally in my savings so I could
use 2,000 of it and then just have to
come up with 3,000 but I feel funny
about taking money out of savings for
grad school I don't know so okay so what
do you need to finish the
three uh
classes's the total just it's just three
credits so what you what's the number
how much um
5400 all right so here's the point um
you need to use the baby steps I mean
work the baby steps yes but just in
addition to what George said you can
come up with the 5400 to get those three
credits and it's worth waiting to get
the 5400 Cash go work go do whatever
sell stuff the point is don't overthink
this you're doing the right thing by
asking this question but now let's just
go get the cash what's your current
income um so to together uh with my
husband we're um
110,000 that's amazing year yeah that's
great you can do this so how long would
it take realistically to save up another
$3
$4,000 with future paychecks well yeah
I'm not sure cuz I um we have a a
287,000 in student loans that's terrible
yeah um and what is this grad school
gonna do for you as far as your career
and your income
well you're going to laugh this is my
second Master's um so I'm Cara what are
we running from here with just chasing
more
education well I think what happened is
during Co when I wasn't allowed to leave
my house I got bored and I was like well
let's just do personal development go to
Europe or something called read book
listen to a podcast for heaven's sakes
listen I know hey Carol but the damage
is done so can I tell you press pause
I've heard enough to know that you don't
need these three credit hours any
anytime
soon yeah I have six years to finish the
degree and I'm three years in so I I
could hold on hold
on you guys you can you need to focus on
getting out of debt we are not worried
about the three extra years there's time
between now and three years where you
can finish that degree right now you
don't need it you don't need to be
focusing on it that's $5,400 that needs
to be going to something else yes George
yes and you you both need more jobs we
need to increase this income cuz you got
a great shovel but the hole is massive
when you got 300 Grand in debt making a
100 it's going to take you forever to
pay this off yeah one master's degree is
enough for you right now to go make some
money to dig out of this okay yeah some
of it's my husbands he's uh he had to
get a doctoral degree in physical
therapy well there's no no it's both you
guys both have it it's not his right
yeah it's all together 287 so how do we
get you both making six figures what are
you doing for
work um I own a music school um and uh
we've got um a good amount of students
and like five teachers how much do you
make um after you know all the
everything probably like n for the
business uh 50,000 so so you're paying
yourself
50,000 yeah okay MH yeah I I think
you've got to be realistically looking
at how can I make 30 to 50
more okay quickly like what what must be
true given the skill set you have the
experience you have for heaven's sakes
you've already got one
Masters yeah what's your first Masters
in um Jazz vocal performance um I'd be
playing gigs I'd be doing private
lessons whatever you need to do on the
side even if it's out of the music
school I I mean I you say that but
unless you can make decent money like I
I don't know I mean if you if there's
some great jazz bars where you can sing
on Friday Saturday nights weddings
you're going to send her to weddings
that could be a great can't be a good
idea nobody wants a jazz singer at
people pay good money to hire jazz bands
really very classy very
tasteful like private events to be fair
I've been married 25 years it's been a
long long time since I've been think
about like a a nice Ramy event we do a
nice cocktail reception get a little
jazz band we hire Cara here's the point
though done I'm not listen I listen I'm
all for you using your gift uh yeah but
I don't know that it's going to Roi
right now and so I want to be making
again I'm not kidding when I say what
must be true for Cara to make an
additional $3 to
$50,000 if you can do that jazzing it up
at the uh wedding great I don't I don't
know scale up the business can we scale
the business exponentially the music
school can can you scale that and get
that yeah I mean I yeah right now we're
doing private lessons but we could offer
like group lessons and try and get more
income that way yeah start brainstorm
with the team for some Revenue
generating ideas like Cara this is this
is massive is the point we're making
that's a lot of debt and and if you let
it stay around it becomes almost
paralyzing the interest alone is going
to be crushing if you guys don't get on
top of this
soon yeah I mean luckily uh we uh like
we both Drive crappy cars um and we're
we've been trying we' paid off like a
personal loan for 10,000 but we haven't
done it kind of in the order we haven't
done it in the order that makes sense um
I'm going to help you guys with that
order we're going to give you one year
of Financial Peace University as well as
one year of every dollar premium so that
you and your husband can get on the same
page get fired up and get angry at this
debt I don't think you're angry enough
right now and that's what we need to do
to get rid of
$287,000 in Consumer Debt we are pushing
for you hang on the line Jen is going to
pick up we'll gift you those resources I
hope it helps is jazzer size still a
thing I don't want it to be a thing but
I think it is okay I will look that up
during the break Ken we'll come back
with some jazzer size aics we'll be back
with an update on jazzer size this is
the ramsy
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from lines drapes and
shutters to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel we're
here for you this hour
8825 5225 now you know we've got all
these social pages and I'm sure if
you're engaged with us you're on some
type of social platform by the way
follow me on Instagram at Ken Coleman
follow George George camel K
Mel uh but but we've got these fun
Community Pages I've got like a a Ken
Coleman official I don't know Facebook
group but our baby steps Community page
on Facebook a lot of fun stuff happening
over there George well there's uh
there's over 410,000 people now in that
group that's right that's massive
massive group so uh what what we've got
here in my hands uh is uh some of the
confessions this just kind of spiked up
I guess in the group Clara confessions
oh yeah these buy now pay later
companies exactly and so we've got a
list here of from the thread of of some
things where uh people admitted the
dumbest thing they have bought now paid
later O So now George you don't remember
this because you're younger than me but
we used to call that like lay
away uh yeah that was like a thing you
know what I mean and so now it's buying
out pay L well now you can get it now
with layway you had to actually you had
to wait for it sit up in the top of the
store you could go in and see the thing
my mom would go well we're going to get
that in a month you know that kind of
thing get you a Stretch Armstrong for
Christmas or something I hope they
didn't lay away the Stretch Armstrong uh
but here we go um so we're going to read
a few of these so Jenna says the dumbest
thing that she uh bought now paid later
were house plants from Etsy rare house
plants apparently she goes on to say
they're still alive and beautiful but
boy that was dumb what a reminder every
day as you look at that you water that
plant you go still paying for that thing
still paying for sucks give me an idea
George what a cost of a plant it feels
like you would know this a rare house
plant I imagine could fetch upwards of
over $100 okay on Etsy wow and said
blankets and nugget play couches now are
those couches that look like chicken
nuggets well no they're just soft play
couches for like kids and stuff oh I
goog you look at me like that was a bad
idea to Google it I hear nugget I hear
play I think what McDonald's has got
their line of toy chicken nugget couch
it's a strange name okay I'll go with
you on that what is the studio audience
you think that was that wasn't that
weird was it she has one oh boy some
guys Point wa speaking of you'll be
sleeping on said couch tonight after
pointing that out God we got to teach
him that's relationship 101 stuff yep
yeah play now pay later yeah there we go
all right what's next uh pelaton that's
not really that surprising yeah you know
cuz that that's a bigger purchase I
think those bikes were over two grand
yeah not anymore I feel like they've
gone down since Co they have indeed the
market has gone down we both had one at
one point Ken didn't we have did no I
sold it yeah me too yeah thought I was
more athletic than I was I I was into it
for a while but then I just got tired of
it well I'm too Frugal you're paying $50
a month for this membership and I'm not
riding this thing it became a clothes
hanger soon after that it was it a cloes
hanger for you yeah I'm not that
motivated Joy said $100 worth of makeup
that I could totally afford at the time
just didn't feel like feeling the money
go out all at once that's the most
common reason people use this even if
they have the money they go I just
didn't feel like spending it all today
now they're spend it all later too which
I'm guessing that's the game that's the
game that's how they get because you
know you have $40 item right below that
add to cart button it says hey why not
pay $10 today and pay 10 bucks for the
next you know three four weeks so mon it
tricks the brain I'm guessing George
into thinking you got a discount exactly
and let me tell you Ken Clara brags
about this to retailers on their website
they say consumers will spend 45% more
in their cart if you put one of these
options on your website uh Angela gets
my award for dumbest buy now pay later
Papa John's gift card because we
couldn't afford food on the financed
vacation okay so you're broke you go on
vacation on the credit card you have no
money you're maxed out and she goes now
we're going to finance a Papa John's
card wow wow buy now pay later pizza
that's a dark place you've got to be in
life I mean you got a payment and
heartburn Papa John's now r Cruz loves
Papa John's is that her favorite pizza
yeah very interesting her favorite chain
Pizza I don't want to put that on her
that it beats you know true Italian
pizza by way she's the only person I
have ever met that can eat the amount of
pizza that she eats and doesn't gain an
ounce that's genetic blessing from the
Ramy uh crew right there Kate said dog
food that's pretty rough you're I see
what you did there it took me a second
took a and you pointed at me I went what
am I supposed to get rough I had to QE
Ken for that one wow how about Michael
with the lawn mower blades for a zero
turn mower again had the money but the
installment plan sounded too easy to
pass up exhibit a you're honor H wow
guys don't fall for this Gina said I use
afterpay and went to history to see what
I've spent when I added it all up I
spent
$8500 on random stuff mainly nail stuff
from Revel Nails Tory bir stuff
Halloween decor and Nikes yikes well the
Tory Birch stuff is pretty pricey she
said Tony Birch but I imagine it's Tori
right I saw you corrected that is there
a Tony Birch who's who's this T please
tell me it's not a knockoff of Tory bur
that's got to be a typo yeah I think she
fat finger on Facebook I've been in the
Tory bir story that's uh pretty pricey
you know that brand Mrs Coleman likes it
not to the tune of $88,500 hopefully
well if I'm paying that I've got I
budgeted for it George and I paid cash
you're not paying later I tell you that
right now last but not least Jamie
uh given Angela a run with the Papa John
gift card Jamie bought movie
tickets and financed $4 movie tickets I
hope they didn't go see Barbie oh wow
yeah you better hope that movie was good
it was Dreadful I'm told to pay that
plus interesting fees I didn't see it my
daughter went to see it but good
gracious well let me tell you this K uh
this is a stat I pulled up a third of us
consumers who use these buy now pay
later options fall behind on one or more
payments which can trigger crazy
interest of up to 30% along with late
fee so everyone says Ken well I'll pay
it later I I have the money now I could
pay it now until you forget I'll kick it
down the road could you imagine paying
30% interest on Papa John's Pizza that's
insult to injury it's just bad or a bad
movie insult to indigestion is what that
is wow no thank you folks don't fall for
these buy now pay later options
psychologically you think well why I pay
40 when I could pay 10 I'll free up some
money in the budget that's what these
companies want you to think here's their
taglines Ken afterpay get what you want
we've got your back affirm pay at your
own pace Clara get financial Breathing
Room nothing says breathing room like
having to pay for something 3 months
later after you've digested it yeah it
literally is a scam like that that's
amazing first one again give me after
pay slow after pay get what you want we
got your back you know what that is you
deserve you know what that is that's the
cool uncle that used to go to his house
and he'd go hey the candy jar is over
top of the stove go in there and get
yourself some candy you know you know
smok a pack of mar
gay kid go get yourself a well I was
trying to give my best Uncle Larry voice
you know but I mean it's like that's
absurd it's literally like be immature
we all had that Uncle or the grandparent
that just didn't care you know what I
mean well they're playing into our
immaturity they're playing into the
toddler inside all of us who said I want
it now I don't want to wait that's it
until then they're gaming us it's insane
and it's caused the generation of broke
people and you'll see if you search this
on Twitter people brag about how broke
they are because of these buy now pay
later Services I tell you the one that
crazy is it gets me is the groceries you
know like a pack of like soda or
something like I've seen that Walmart
you could get a pack of Cokes yeah you
showed it to me on payments of you know
what 37 cents $1.78 for the next three
months it's
nonsensical and would they charge you
interest if you didn't do that oh 100%
they all have different terms and
conditions but the bigger thing can is
that it causes you to overspend I mean
you saw that stat I showed you from
Clara bragging to retailers you're gonna
spend 45% more if you're psychologically
thinking well I'm spending less today
therefore I can put more in the cart
yeah if I can spend 25% of that amount
I'll feel better about packing that c is
George this speaks to the fact that
these businesses exist and they're
crushing it they're becoming billion
dollar Industries they somebody just
woke up these are smart people by the
way you may say they're evil sure but
maybe they're not they're just smart
they're going you know what we have a
culture of people who think they deserve
everything and they deserve it now and
nobody has the money now cuz all broke
yeah but they don't any money because
they're too busy getting stuff they
deserve that they can't afford and this
really is a behavioral issue we got a
lot of new people joining us all the
time and a little mini rant on that you
know you got to get to a point where
where where you realize that delayed
gratification is the secret sauce to
success in any area of your life
relationally emotionally spiritually
physically financially professionally
learn how to say no to yourself it's a
game changer short-term convenience has
a long-term cost Ken don't fall for it
there is I don't have a mic in my hand
but I have a pencil or otherwise known
as a kencel and I'll drop that there it
is the Barbie reference full circle
don't move more Ramsey show coming right
[Music]
up hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel the
phone number for you to jump in this
hour is
8825 5225 let's go to Naisha in Dallas
Texas Naisha how can we
help hi I am calling in because I need
help with a budget and my income is
not I don't have enough income to cover
my budget and I'm behind
okay repo and I just I I need to know
where where do I where do I start where
do I well you've got the dynamic duo for
those two issues let's get the budget
under control first George take it away
and then we'll work on some income stuff
yeah Naisha give us a give us a
financial picture how much do you make
and how much debt do you
have okay um I make about 56 a year and
I receive child support um about
10,000 a year
and I have about
$215,000 in debt and that does include
my mortgage and my car okay so let's
separate the mortgage out we'll save
that for later on down the road what
what does the other debt add up
to um I also have so my car that's
23,000 I have 9500 in student
loans and I have about 12,000 in credit
cards okay this helps me now so once we
parse out the mortgage it's looking like
you have let's see about
$45,000 in Consumer
Debt yes okay that gives us a number we
can work with now you said the car is
about to get repoed are you behind on
payments yes how far
behind I'm like two payments behind in
October I think I'll make three payments
okay I think October May three payments
can you sell the car what's it worth so
I've tried to the car and dealers are
dealers are offering me like 11,000 well
dealers are the worst place to go to
sell a car cuz they're in it to make
money yeah you want to sell a private
party to someone who can give you a lot
more for it have you looked at the the
Kelly Blue Book value private party for
what it's
worth not private party I haven't okay
I've only did it okay my guess is that's
going to be closer to 15 16 what is it
what kind of car is it it's a um 2017
Infiniti
QX60 that should sell for a pretty penny
how many
miles I have 130,000
miles 2017 Infiniti QX60 130,000 miles
Ken's doing some beautiful mind maath in
here somehow well I actually you know
I've been I'm shopping for cars for
teenagers I'm pretty well versed in this
that that should be getting private
party you should be getting in the $6 to
$220,000 range there we go uh I
absolutely believe that'll hold up I
think it's closer to 20 so we've got to
look at that as a viable option we we'll
come back to that if we have time but
you have got to get some help if you're
not confident in that how to put it on
Facebook Marketplace look up Kelly
Bluebook today put the VIN number in
this will take you three minutes to get
an actual real number okay please do
that because I think you've got to look
at that because that's going to change
your life if you get rid of that debt
yeah and that that car is staring you
down it's I think getting rid of that
would give you a lot of Peace it would
just give you the student loan and the
car the credit card to focus on right
yes okay and do you have any money
currently
budget um so I got paid today and that
was a short check so I don't have any
savings right now um no savings I've
already started um trying to sell things
so I can have an emergency
fund
um yeah so I are you current on all of
your other bills $1200 right now okay
you got 1,200 bucks and you're current
on all of the bills except for the car
payment so my mortgage I did a repayment
plan with that my mortgage is normally
1,500 a month the repayment plan added
,000 onto my mortgage so starting
November 1st my mortgage payments will
be 2500 you can't afford that can you no
I can't what is this for payment plan
about with the mortgage
company because I got
behind are you able to afford this house
longterm or do we need to get rid of it
longterm I can't afford the house if I
stick to a budget and I got off my
budget issue it really wasn't a budget
it was just I was paying I was paying
bills um regularly how long do you have
to pay the extra thousand for six months
it's six payments that's most of your
take-home pay
right so which means we're going to get
behind on the other payments which means
we're going to stay in this vicious
cycle
forever how many kids do you have I have
four two are in college that's both I
don't they have full rid so they have
tuition is taken care of and I have two
toddlers okay bless you how much is the
house worth do you think if you were to
put it on the
market um the house can sell for about
aund and I think 70 or 80,000 I even
consider putting it on um putting it up
for sale no do not do for sale by owner
if that's what you're talking about no I
I actually I had a a realtor okay and we
were putting we were going to put it on
the market the only thing is what we
needed to list it for I needed more than
that to buy me another place to live and
to pay my debt off okay well you can go
rent for a while couldn't
you I could and the rent will be more
than my mortgage even with this payment
plan it's not going to be more than
2500 uh so for me to find a an apartment
here in the Dallas area two bedrooms are
starting at like 14 $1,500 can you can
you move further outside of the
city I've considered that and it's so I
have to I have to be somewhat close to
daycare
MH and I don't want to sound like I'm
making excuses but I've tried all of
this yeah well we we don't hear excuses
we sound someone who is a warrior who
has been through a lot who's in a really
tough pinch so we're not here to yell at
you we want to help you we're trying to
look at all of the options yes to help
you get out of this mess as fast as
possible that's right and we're not
saying that you need to sell the house
we're just asking is that a viable
option because to the extent that we
relieve pressure on you the quickest
that we can that's what we're trying to
I'd rather you be in control of the home
sale versus it being forced through a
foreclosure I agree and you're head
you're staring down the barrel of
that because with the Children daycare
do you have the ability to to to work
more to to make some more money uh do
you feel like I'm going to give you the
increase your income bundle okay that's
it's got a bunch of goodies in it cuz I
think we've got to increase your income
and and to the extent like quickly to
give you some breathing I have I have
I've applied for um another full-time
job to work like on the weekends I'm
working overtime at my job I also do
crafts on the side and um I sell those
that's not it's not consistent not a
consistent income Revenue that I could
even consider I'm currently in a I'm
currently in two courses one two free
courses that is to get my life insurance
license and to get my real estate
license I wrote a policy last night so
I'll receive that income but it's not
immediately it's delayed okay all right
so here's what we need to do so what I
want to give it back to George for a
second but can what we what we are going
to do uh Naisha we're going to get you
um some free sessions on us with one of
our financial coaches is um we can't go
into all the details that you need um
right now on the air and our coaches it
is going to be our gift to you and so
we're GNA so you I want you to stay on
the line in just a moment um and we're
going to get you connected and they're
going to walk you through the nitty gree
of the budget and so here's what I
wanted to te George up on just to
encourage you uh George what can she do
right now we're going to get over a
coach but the budget side of things I
think if she begins to get control of
the money uh she's going to have a
better chance of digging out of this
yeah your A1 is to create some margin
and the only ways to do that is to make
more and to spend less and your sounds
like you're doing both of those things
to the best of your ability I think we
might need to go to our credit union and
get a small loan to cover the difference
that you might be missing on that car
when you sell it and get you something
uh cheap right now maybe a $6,000 car
$5,000 car to get you around for now
that will get you out of this hole and
give you some hope for the future so
hang on the line Jen is going to pick up
we'll give you the increase your income
bundle and those financial coaching sets
sessions we wish you the best Naisha
you're going to get out of this hang on
we believe in you this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the ramsy way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's Ramsey
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions this is the ramsy show
it's where we help people win in their
life specifically their money their work
and their Rel relationships I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague and
dear pal George camel with a K Ka Mel
that's right 8825 5225 8825 5225 and
we're excited to be with you we always
enjoy being together we have a lot of
fun uh sitting in here together we
actually sit next to each other uh in
the uh in the office well double
blessing and uh we enjoy helping people
George is here to help you with your
money I'm here to help you with your
work issues those work and money issues
go hand inand and so we want to help you
win in those areas today triple
5225 let's go to Tim who joins us now in
Grand Rapids Michigan Tim how can we
help hello hello Tim you're live on the
Ramsey show all right how are you guys
we're having a blast how can we
help uh I work in the automotive
industry and my job just got affected by
that
and ah um is that due to the strike
child support yeah it's due to the
strike yeah we're A supplier
okay yep have you been laid off drowning
not laid off but I was able to work
overtime and that was keeping me
somewhat afloat due to excessive uh
child support okay and so the overtime
pay has gone
away yeah okay so what are you making
now now it's um I haven't done the math
yet I just was told yesterday at the end
of the day and then today was the first
day that my hours were I always were cut
okay what do they cut down
to uh eight hours a day so a 40 hour
week I was working 50 55 hours before
okay so we're still at 40 hours and that
will cut your pay just by that hourly
rate right okay and you have no idea
what that could
be
it's been a while since I've looked at
my monthly take-home but I'm guessing
that you know with this cut I'm going to
be make or taking home about $450 a week
after all of the um stuff is taken out
of it
garnished oh for child
support yeah because I have to pay like
70% of my income and child support right
now
wow okay and what's your question today
what can I do to help out I don't know
how long this is going to last I've
talked to my boss about it and he's not
sure either he's just like I'm just
doing what I'm told I'd have you work
more if I could but you know you can
only do so much yeah yeah well let me
also say that there's we we don't know
how long this the strike is going to
last is it going to continue to expand
right now it's just kind of a partial
rolling out version of the strike so
nobody has any control over that so
you've got to take the initiative and so
you've got got to find you've already
been working 55 60 hours a week if I
heard you correctly so guess what I'd be
doing if I were you I'd be working 55 to
60 hours a week you got 40 with your
current employer you've got some skill
set you've got some experience you've
got connections out there and you've got
to go make some money and you've got to
stay where you are to stay afloat and
then I you need to revisit things with
your lawyer it seems to absurd to me
you're not making crazy money I don't
have enough money to pay him he said I
not going to rep represent you anymore
until you get me a lump sum and pay x
amount per month do you need to I do
something contact the courts and the
judge and say hey we need to relook at
this based on my new income yeah call
the judge directly you don't need a
lawyer to show the judge your
income how do I do that recalculate it
based on this new income
yeah one of the biggest misnomers in the
world is that you got to have a lawyer
in this situation because you're you're
dealing with the judge you're not you're
not arguing a divorce case you're not
you're just literally you you've the
child support's already been established
the judge is the one that makes that
decision I'm just telling you what I
would do George step in here if I
started to say something that's careless
but I would be on the phone with the
clerk office of the judge and go look
here's my situation I can't even afford
a lawyer but I can show everything I got
I got my utilities I got all the bills
this is my situation I just got my hours
cut you know but it seems absurd that
70% of your income is going to child
support
my ex-wife physically attacked me and
then told the court that I had attacked
her and she basically has a kid three
three of them three daughters just about
fulltime that's why okay the only thing
somewhat saving me is the fact that
there is some sort of limit on wage
garnishment other otherwise you know now
if you go make this side income is that
going to be garnished as
well if I make side income it might be
okay if I don't exceed what I was making
before um the strike started but
anything I make above that that's now
then going to determine the new level of
Tri and if I voluntary ever ever
voluntarily decrease my income than the
child support remains at the higher
level man I'm sorry to hear you going
through all this yeah that's a little
bit more complex so yeah this when you
start talking about accusations of abuse
and stuff like that that's not that's a
different ball game so strike what I
said from that but uh I I I also would
tell you
that you have to make more income even
if they take more of it you still got to
create margin for yourself and then
George I think he's really got to figure
out so so here's the deal if I'm you
because I want to turn it over to George
on the budget stuff you gota you gotta
cut cut cut cut cut everywhere you can
uh but I would tell you you're a number
one as soon as you hang up is how do you
get 15 more hours at least keeping your
income at the same level that you were
at George yeah um what kind of debt do
you have right now
Tim uh IRS about 4,000 attorney fees
about
26,000 U 26,000 in attorney
fees right was this all from the divorce
to
now right apart from that I would have
no no
debt but how they they were okay doing
all of this without any payment
yeah and then um last
December um was the last time uh we had
a conversation he's like no I need a I
need a bump sum $3,000 and then
something like3 to $500 per month in
order to continue representing you and
sounds like you need a new lawyer but
you still owe this guy
money I still owe that guy money then I
have no nothing for a retainer for
another guy I mean
you got the IRS debt anything
else
um IRS lawyer uh back child support
there're still about 4500 left in that
man we have got to clean this mess up
and get you to a good foundation you are
underwater right now and I wish we had
time to dig into it all um but what we
need to do is revisit all this with the
courts and go listen here's my income
here's my all of my debts I phys I can't
pay this child support going forward we
need to figure out a new plan whether
that's I've said that in court before
but they still said well doesn't matter
you still owe this yeah I I actually
think George in this situation his his
focus is needing to be let's go get more
income and you've got to get uh you got
to get your budget under control let's
let's we got to give him I'd love
another Financial coach session for him
let's do it to get everything under
control forgot where everything's going
where it's coming in hang on the line
we're going to get you a free session
with one of our great financial coaches
and they can dig into some resources
locally for you as well do what they
tell you to do they will build a map for
you out of this so sorry you're going
through this this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agent gencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with why refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
George camel we are here for you this
hour
8825 5225 taking your questions about
your money and your work situation many
times those are very
intertwined and uh we're happy that
you're here 8825
5225 the Ramy show question of the day
is here and it's sponsored by our
friends at neighborly your hub for Home
Services take your homes efficiency and
style to the next level with convenient
solutions from shelf Genie window Genie
which by the way was George's nickname
in high school and Glass Doctor download
the neighborly app now to find and
schedule home service professionals near
you thank you for that Ken yes today's
question comes from Leighton in Arizona
when do you decide to get a new to you
car we're having no problems with any of
them but mine is almost at 150,000 Mi do
you wait until your car starts breaking
down do you wait until it dips to a
certain percentage of the original price
or some other criteria I feel like like
that question is like customade for you
I love this question you probably have a
hack for this and I'm actually
interested to know I don't there's no I
don't have a certain formula I'm not a
uh a car guy I put that in quotes cuz
when people say they're car guys all
that means is they make really dumb
decisions when it comes to their car
buying and they justify it because
they're a car guy I don't know I think
car guys are going to take offense to
that George I think Car Guy means now
there's there's broke car guys and then
there's Dave Ramsey who's a car guy so
let me caveat it that not all guys are
created equal okay I think there's one
of be Car Guys which is your
classification which is you and there's
car guys who like they like to get
underneath the hood of a car oh sure
they get the grease under the
fingernails they understand things like
does it have a hem you see what I'm
saying that's a car guy but financially
cars are depreciating assets some would
call them liabilities and so this is not
an investment so I'm a big fan of buying
a new to you car so buying a used car
unless you're worth millionaire that's
when you can get a new car if you should
so choose and at that point drive it
till the wheels fall off if you want to
get the maximum
Roi so she's saying hey it's at 150,000
miles do I wait until it's breaking down
uh you don't have to wait until it
starts breaking down but I would set up
a car syncing fund I like that what that
means is in your budget you set aside a
certain amount every single month let's
call it $200 that's 2400 bucks a year
and in two years that's almost five
grand in four years it's almost 10 grand
and so over the years as you drive this
car which most cars will go way longer
than we allow them to Ken most people
think I got to it's been four years it's
like an iPhone now got to get a new car
can I've had this one for four years
it's starting to smell a little bit get
it detailed I promise you a professional
detail for 100 bucks yeah will make you
go oh I got a brand new car stop letting
your kids throw the french fries in the
floor there you go I mean there's things
we can do here so and 150,000 mil
depending on the car is not a lot of
miles right but I think you could see
the handwriting on the wall so I'm
jumping into where you're at here going
all right if it's got 150,000 mil but
it's in really good shape uh and I know
I can get probably two more years out of
it three more years without a lot of
issues um then I'm starting the sinking
fund to your point and maybe I sell it
once I get the replacement fund where I
needed to be so that I get the maximum
money for it yes so there's that to take
most of the depreciation has already
happened when you had 150,000 mil and so
if you're going to sell a car you know
you want to do it before it hits that
100 Mark that's what people start to get
spooked that it's going to have all
kinds of issues but if this is a Honda
or a Toyota yeah like how go 300,000 Mi
I just checked the mileage on my car I'm
sitting at
181,000 and I'm going to ride that thing
till yeah but it's a Tesla yeah it's a
you you you the miles don't matter on
those things that's the thing they can
go up you know 500,000 or more it's the
battery so all that to say I don't see
miles as an indication necessarily
depending on the car but I would you
know you can get an inspection on it and
if you start to see things start
breaking down I'd get that syncing fund
up and going so that you are ready when
that car does break down number one you
have the repairs fund going with your
emergency fund but also have a sinking
fund ready for you to buy a new to you
car good great question though yeah
thank you for the question Isaac is up
next in Columbus Ohio Isaac how can we
help hi so I have a question so little
backstory here so my my wife and I just
got married two weeks ago
today very exciting oh yes thank you so
um we we have a little bit of debt
between ourselves um she had to get a
car about a year ago um that with her
trading and everything that was about
8,000 um and then I think her car right
now before interest is uh 18,000 my car
is a little older um my car pay payment
will be eight about
8500 um to pay off um not including the
interest so I got a about two more years
on that um expected um and then a couple
thousand in credit card debts aside from
that we're we don't have any other debts
no student loans we don't have a
mortgage yet we're wanting to buy house
um and that's our that's our largest
goal we want to be established in our
first home before we start having
children um we live in a currently live
in a one-bedroom apartment and it's kind
of you know we're kind of busting out of
the walls we're not minimalists by any
means but um okay hold on a second hold
on second yes I want to set some
expectations for you my young friend uh
it's just you and the wife there's no
way you're busting out unless it's a
cardboard box you're not busting out of
it I you know what I mean do you have
like seven cats or anything weird no we
actually don't have any pets because our
uh uh apartment has a crazy $400 pet
deposit okay good you just have too much
crap you have to get rid of your crap
dude go we do we we are collectors for
sure well then okay but here's the point
the reason I I jumped in here I want to
get you back on Pace but this is the
kind of stuff that pushes you to make
bad financial decisions on a house you
think it's just you and your wife get
rid of all of her stuffed animals or
something whatever's going on what are
you collecting I don't understand how
you guys are busting out of a
one-bedroom apartment well it's it's
actually kind of funny so we we we like
uh geology and stuff like that and we
like artifacts like uh just like
crystals and like arrowheads and just
natural stuff like that so we've got El
of it but uh we're trying to we're
trying to downsize we give stuff away to
people who like the similar stuff we
give it away as gift so we can kind of
like maintain a healthy amount without
hoarding um yeah I was got to say what's
a healthy amount of arrowheads I mean
how many Arrow can one person have we
got slow roll with the rock collection
cuz we got a pile of dead to clean up
now's not the time to be buying rocks
sure yeah no we're not really doing that
it's mainly just going out on uh going
on trails and uh uh in rivers and stuff
and stuff would be fine I'll tell youa
that's good well but I'm going to tell
you to stop collecting rocks and
arrowheads and start
working extra jobs and that's the thing
I I asked so for my job I'm a home
health aid and I I do I like live in the
position so three days a week I'm not
home and my base hours is 72 hours a
week oh okay I don't know how you have
time to find arrowheads with that
schedule yeah you're not in the
apartment long enough to hate it
downtime okay what do you we we're
barely there um my wife uh is in the
transitional period of her new job so
she just uh got hired she starts the
23rd of this month awesome um she's yeah
so she's going to be making uh take home
Pro estimated about $7 800 a week um I
do about 9 to 11 depending on overtime
okay so what would be your monthly
take-home pay between the two of you
starting in a few weeks between the two
of us it would be expected to be around
6 to 6,300 awesome that's great news so
then the question becomes how quickly
can we can we pay off these cars and the
credit cards making 6,300 if we're doing
nothing but focused on paying off debt
right and that's and that's actually how
we got married so quickly we we didn't
want to pay we didn't want to finance
anything uh we spent the past year and
maybe 15 months maybe just absolutely
saving everything we could paying things
as we go along um just being absolutely
crazy with with saving because we didn't
want to put anything on the credit card
um in fact because of how crazy we did
it we I wish we had had more savings by
the time it was done but do you have any
right now because yes we have we have
about $2,300 in C um 13 in cash and
about 1,100 in uh our savings account
okay you have your baby step one starter
emergency fund the rest of this money
needs needs to go towards paying off
this debt do the debt snowball smallest
to largest get on a budget we're not
doing anything except paying off this
debt no rock collecting no Arrowhead
collecting nothing man bust it you got
this good stuff thank you
George more coming up right after this
this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
all right America we're here to help you
win in your money your work and your
relationships this is the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman George Campell is with
me today triple 8825 5225 is the number
for you to jump in let's go to Seattle
Washington Sandra is on the line Sandra
how can we
help hi I'm seeking wisdom so I have two
questions the first one is when should I
sell my house and the second is when
should my husband find job he enjoys
within the field he's in or call it good
and go back to school so I'm going to
throw some numbers at you we take we
bring home together
$125,000 a year 74 of that is myself the
rest is um my husband we have 30,00
a little over
30,200 in debt 1,500 of that is Consumer
Debt 8,700 of that is student loan and
20 of that is a loan that my mom gave me
to um put down towards the house that we
currently live in right
now and um so yeah the house that I live
in I think that I can get about 400 for
it I owe 200 um so my initial thought
was sell the house list it uh January
sell it put that money into a bond or
some type of savings and
then um while we so so let me back up a
little bit we're we are aiming to pay
off all the debt including my mom by
early March latest April and so my
thought was this would be the first time
we ever have money in our hands it would
give us a chance to restart to let him
really find a career that he enjoys go
to renting and we don't have anything
really holding us down but I don't know
if that's why just because you know
we're not drowning right now but I me
what's your reason for selling the house
because not it's not your Consumer
Debt no so the house the neighborhood is
going to crap there was there was a
driveby shooting right down the street
it's like our tree is fine it's
everything around us is just there's a
lot of how far outside of Seattle would
you need to go to find a safe
neighborhood so I'm not in Seattle I'm
in I'm about three hours away in in uh
Tri Cities but um I guess to to be safer
I would actually in a safer neighborhood
I would be closer to my job um and I
mean the houses that we're looking at in
that area are about
500 um okay so let we were thinking so
let's jump in here for a second uh
so if I were in your situation and the
neighborhood around me was going to crap
I would be getting out of
Dodge and the fact that you've got some
equity in this home right now is great
so you don't have to sell it to clean up
the de
debt um I like the fact that with your
husband's I mean he's still got some
great income potential so to you and the
fact that you're already in on track to
pay off this Consumer Debt in just about
six months or less that's great are you
saying you'd pay that off if you sold
the house or with reg no I'm regardless
the house is also old and it's breaking
down like I'm ding beaters my H going
out okay sell it so okay so then that
would lead to the next question so is it
stupid for us to let that money sit for
two years while he tries to figure out
what he wants to do for a career like is
that unwise I don't think it's got to be
two years I'm not sure where you're
pulling that number but no it's not on
wise on the surface of well number one
you're going to take the equity whatever
the profits you get from the sale of
this house and you're going to pay off
the debt which is 30k you need an
emergency fund which is probably another
20 25k right MH so all of a sudden
you've got 100K that's sitting in a high
yield savings account parked for your
future home purchase I'm going to call
it a Down payment fund for a future home
maybe you guys rent for a year keep
saving up get yourself in a good
Financial spot he gets the new job great
now we're ready to purchase a new home
and and the question I've got is are you
guys wanting to stay in Washington state
or is he's looking for this this career
are you guys open to going
anywhere we're we're starting to open
our minds to going anywhere we just like
it's Taboo in our family like St I get
that the rest of your you're going to
end up resenting it's a cultural
difference yes will present them yeah so
so we make that decision now that we're
going to go where we feel led to go yeah
yeah all right so but let's keep it to
the finance piece I'd sell the house
George just told you what we would do
next you you you immediately finish baby
step two instantaneously upon the
account getting hit with your your money
left over after you sold the home and
now you've got the emergency fund
instantaneously now we put the rest of
the money in a hide yield savings
account and your husband
uh is is getting after it you know and I
I'll give him some great resources I'll
give him my get clear work assessment
today my gift to you okay and he's going
to know maybe for the first time in his
life what he's really good at doing what
he loves to do and the results that
motivate him that's where the ideas come
from as he begins to pick his
professional path and so and then he
figures out all right I know what I want
to do why I want to do it where I can do
it now how do I get qualified for it
that's the next part in the decision
process hopefully he doesn't have to go
back to school but if he does you guys
cash flow it maybe he can get by with
some certifications or qualifications I
announced on my show today Walmart just
went public one of the next big
companies uh one of the latest rather to
say that they're moving a lot of
corporate jobs into a situation where
you don't need a degree so as this
economy evolves a degree I'm just going
to put this out there really quick if if
it's not the only way or the best way
for your husband to get qualified to do
what he wants to do don't assume that
that college or degree is necessary can
we start
there yeah no that's I guess my concern
is so he's a mechanical engineer and
he's like talking about going to
teaching so that's the other reason for
some I mean that's a big drop you know
from the 125 that we're at right now
well well what's he you're making 74 so
he's making 50 he's making
50 well he's not making a lot of money
for a mechanical engineer in fact I
would say he's
bottom so if he wants to be a
teacher well I just want I just want to
I want to operate with facts okay the
the
median uh salary for a teacher in the
United States right now is around
$63,000 give or take it may be 61 last
time I check but it's somewhere in that
range so that's not a drop for
him yeah and so let me also say this if
he wants to think about teaching he
needs to hang out with some people that
are teaching in the spaces that he
thinks he wants to teach is it higher
red is it k through 12 he needs to spend
some time with people that are doing
that and figure out if in fact that's
what he wants to
do okay all right that's very
important but I think you guys know what
we want you to do financially this is
pretty straightforward but for him going
forward it's what does he want to do
let's get around people that are doing
that and let's figure out after I've
talked to them and I've heard The Good
the Bad and the Ugly do I still want to
do that because I the America needs more
teachers but I will tell you that
America needs to fix the classroom
situation so that we don't have the
teachers that are leaving at the level
that they're leaving right now it's a
four alarm dumpster fire and so before
you go into teaching he needs to know
what he's dealing with it's not the
teacher's Fault by the way but it is an
increasingly tough
environment so I want him to be sure
that that's what he wants to
do yeah know me too I mean he worked as
a Pera when he was doing his undergrad
but I don't know if that's enough
experience for him yeah no I think what
you're saying is perfect I think that
would be very wise for him yeah you ask
for wisdom that's that's that's about
the wisest thing he can do before he
picks A New Path sit Shadow sit with
people that are doing it Shadow them get
a good look or else it's just this
romanticized idea and he has no idea you
know I want to sit with a teacher at the
end of the day who's had one of the
worst days of their life and go why was
it awful and and and then I want to know
can if am I willing to do that and if
the answer is yes ding ding ding we got
a winner so uh I really appreciate the
question but that's uh financially we
told you what to do I I would love for
them to move quickly on this because by
the way
George this will take the financial
stress out of the decision oh 100% he's
not going backwards if he goes into
teaching not right now yeah we'll get
that income back up in no time and
you're going to continue to make more
money so I'd make the necessary repairs
you need to make on this house to sell
it to get what you need for it and I get
rid of this debt get yourself in a good
Financial spot and we can work on his
career from there yeah good stuff hang
on the line we'll get you the get clear
assessment for your husband this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks Dr John delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's three mon months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
is free imagine the peaceful habits you
can establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me the phone
number is 88255 225 all right George uh
who needs to call us today well you know
we got a lot of new people all the time
and this idea of well they've been
listening for long show is is
intimidating for some people so what
kind of calls you think this is the day
to call I think you and I are the least
intimidating bunch of guys you could run
into in an Alleyway the by the way the
studio audience is also validating this
I mean who's going to be scared to talk
to us look at us we're not big men
number one I take offense to that you do
I never said it wasn't true I just said
I take offense to it I I'm fine being
just an average sized guy I'm okay with
it we have giant personalities that's
true well there's a lot of people out
there Ken cuz I talk I get these DMS on
Instagram all the time and people say
hey I need help and I go call the show I
can't help you over a DM it's good
format yeah they'll call me up and go
Ken listen I'm in a situation here where
my boss is doing this I feel like I'm
being overlooked I've got a promotion
over here blah BL and they give me all
these details I can't answer that in the
DM we have to have the back and forth
much too much thumbs and uh so here's
the deal today the day it's a free call
do you are you aware of this a toll-free
number George I don't if times get tough
we could start charging we could Triple
8 825 5225 is the number you got a work
question you feel like you're stuck you
feel confused I don't know what I want
to do with my life I want to Pivot uh I
want to make more money is starting a
job is starting a company the way to get
out of debt anything related to that
George will take any of the budgeting
question can we do something fun next
person that calls in with a career
question gets your get clear assessment
for free how about that in fact you know
we'll go above and beyond that we'll
also give them the uh the uh increase
your income bundle the whole thing so
you get you get my book from payche to
purpose you get the assessment they get
clear work assess I'm calling the show
right now get hired course I have a
whole course there's a lady out there
now she's trying to call in you can't
call in from the lobby that's the lobby
doesn't count I'll just give it to you
cuz I'm nice all right cuz you're so
nice out there um all right so that's
fun I thought you were going to say a
fun topic like we should say we're going
to take calls on this no that feels
risky all right too dicey we have but
let's get to the calls Ken speaking of
which Speaking of which the now now the
phones are lighting up that's all we had
to say is that we were going to be nice
Scott is on the line in Indianapolis
Scott how can we help George Ken thanks
for taking the call I I'm intimidated by
you guys and uh but I don't have a word
question so I guess I I sunk pass I'll
figure out something no I tell you what
I'm gonna think of something while
George answers your Finance question I'm
gonna come up with something to give
away all right guys um so I really have
kind of two two issues going on side by
side uh I have a wife I'm trying to come
up with something to to help her join me
on on managing her budget right now
she's kind of refusing to get involved
and along those same lines we have a uh
a large purchase we're considering it's
it's uh expensive and time critical and
really be a good time to get on the same
page and we're not really who wants to
make this
purchase we both do okay what is the
purchase can you tell us uh I mean it's
I'm I'm 56 she's 40 and we want another
kid we want to purchase a kid medical
help doing it whoa whoa whoa
time wait wait wait are you joking when
you say purchase a
kid no using IVF oh okay I mean I had to
ask it threw me off I was okay so where
are you guys at financially today as it
stands do you have any debt and what's
your
income um the only debt we have uh we're
we're davish so we do things a little
difference uh no mortgage no payments
the only uh we've been married for two
years uh I brought brought in the debt
of about 18,000 that's down from 100,000
and that was U medical bills from my
previous wives okay so you still have
the medical bills yes anything else no
okay and what's the household
income um combined we make about the
same we're doing about 9,000 a month
awesome okay that's a that's a great
shovel so we can clean up this medical
debt quickly do you have an emergency
fund yes okay so you're right on the D
part and you're trying to get her on
board what is the current hesitation on
her
part well um just a little background
she came she was raised poor family uh
her previous marriage was he was a overs
spender and she had to manage the books
uh I managed the books and in in my
marriage uh so I thought it'd be kind of
a great combination coming together I
made the mistake of saying well since
you've never had money I'll let you keep
your income in a separate account oh boy
and yeah
so you guys currently don't have
combined bank accounts right and it's
because of two previous marriages there
was Financial trauma that happened in in
various ways it sounds like right so
there's a very kind of scarcity
mentality from her upbringing plus the
financial abuse that she experienced in
her previous marriage so she's coming to
the table with a lot of financial
baggage that we have to get to the root
of and do you feel like you're
triggering a lot of this when you you're
talking hey I'm going to manage this
here's what going to do we're going to
get on the budget and she's starting to
get a little skittish about the whole
thing yeah it's probably at that point
where I'm you know aggressively trying
to get her involved and you know it's
probably it's pushing her away I think
well what is her her longing does she is
she wanting a child is that what's the
real why behind why she why should she
get on this budget what's in it for
her
um she yeah that's yeah that's what I've
been trying to actually use is you know
we've we've got this we we don't really
have the money for it but if you know we
work together on this you know and i'
I've thrown out a couple offers as far
as you know if she gets paid for her
summer work or I get uh you know end of
year bonus I you know we can go ahead
and use that money for it the chance of
success is only
25% so obviously I'm a little reluctant
to with those odds to even go into this
ADV uh Venture yeah I'm willing to you
know is she all right let's talk about
the relationship part so obviously
you're not on the same page and I'm
guessing that you've said to her
multiple times I want us to combine
income uh combine bank accounts and all
this and work together has she just said
full stop no way I'm not
interested yes so it's non-negotiable to
this point she said no no
thanks yes all right how bad does she
want a child at
40 badly and you've told her we don't
have the money to afford it what does
she say to that
um I you know I think she's willing to
go into debt for that and that's where
I've kind of said you know we need to
see a couple things first before we do
that okay and how'd that go
over um you know I think she's just
driven to you know she she wants to to
try for another child not let me read
between the lines so you she said no you
said we need to combine our incomes
finances all this she said nope uh then
she said I want a baby and you said okay
but we don't have the money so we need
to do this this and this and her reply
was I don't care I want the baby am I
I'm not trying to make you uncomfortable
but this is important is that what I'm
hearing she's like thanks but no thanks
we're doing
it yes my friend this is like you guys
are misaligned on core Financial values
well this is going to wreck your
relationship I want you to fast forward
for 30 seconds you go ahead and give in
cuz she's dug a she's she's dug in and
so we either come to a a compromise of
what we both want she wants the baby you
want to pay cash for it we compromise on
that or we don't move forward on this
that's my position and it ought to be
your position because if you give in and
this isn't about right or wrong but if
you you and it doesn't work which
there's a 75% chance it doesn't work I'm
hoping for the best my wife and I went
through it it did not work for us so I'm
speaking from a place of of intimate
knowledge of the situation we paid
cash uh you will resent her
tremendously and and and I also got news
for you she'll probably want to try
again now you think about that
future because I think this is a
difficult conversation and probably with
a marriage counselor or a pastor that's
what I think this
is
yeah I've listened to the show enough
where I that's that's probably what I
was thinking the advice was going to be
well this is just such an emotionally
charged conversation because we're not
just talking about a frivolous purchase
of a pool okay this is our family we're
talking about so Scott hang on the line
I'm going to do my best effort to get
you guys on the same page by gifting you
onee Financial Peace University have her
watch all the lessons just have say hey
all I'm asking is that you sit down and
watch these lessons with me and I'm also
going to give you every dollar premium
to make budgeting even easier and what
you're going to do it's not I'm handling
it or you're handling it we're going to
look at this together and craft a plan
to help us create this future both
financially and for our family so hang
on the line we'll give to you those
resources good stuff George good hour
thank you America for listening this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a week
newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically winning with your money
winning in your work and winning in your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel the phone number for you
Isle 8825
8825 5225 we love taking your questions
we're going to be nice we're going to
try to be entertaining as well as equip
you to move forward and if you don't
like the jokes and the little side
comments well you can tune in when two
other no change the channel just another
day it'll be with two other people but
uh I'm getting more and more George the
little comments about the root beer
float which we were once referred to by
a listener in com a podcast review on I
believe it was a podcast review and appr
so more and more people are saying they
like the root beer float so uh uh we
don't know who's the root beer we don't
know who the vanilla is George has his
opinions I don't know if I agree I
digress I think you're the float I think
I'm the root beer you're the float well
it's the same thing the root beer float
you mean the vanilla ice cream yes you
think I'm the vanilla ice cream you're
smooth you're
cool you're liked by everyone I don't
know if that's true root beer you know
not Everyone likes that flavor Ken but
it's got a little bit of spice to it
little zing and that's you little Zing
little Zing I see what you're doing
there all right we'll get off of that
topic quickly and moved to Las Vegas
Nevada where or is it Nevada Nevada or
Nevada it's Nevada technically
but Nevada in my heart can I get a
ruling in the booth is it Nevada or
Nevada what do you think most people
think anyone that lives there will say
Nevada inclusing including Sarah she's
gonna say it okay Sarah Will Tell Us
Sarah you're on the ramsy show is it
Nevada or
Nevada it's Nevada and that's the only
way only way I will start to change it
because I lean towards the ah not the a
right okay how can we help so I am
selling my house and moving out of
Nevada um and building a new house in
Denver Colorado so between houses my
family and I we have about like four to
six months and we're going to have about
half a million from the sale of this
house cash that we take away what is a
good like what should we do with that
half a million while we're just waiting
about the four to six months until we
put it down on our next house okay okay
so there's going to be a gap of 6 months
between the the sale of this one and the
purchase of the next one and you just
want to know where to park
it yeah okay if I'm in your shoes I'm
going to go with a high yield savings
account okay and that would be a I would
you have a a
spouse yeah okay you want to make sure
that it's FDIC insured and that would
give you each 250k of protection which
should be perfect if you have 500k
sitting in that joint high yield savings
account
okay and that'll give you about you know
4% some of these 5% maybe even a little
more and uh you know you take $500,000 I
mean a h 100,000 you have 5% that's five
grand right so we're talking 25 Grand in
one year so split that in half you're
going to make 12 Grand guaranteed if the
interest rates don't
change okay sounds good so I would not
invest the money I wouldn't put it in a
0% I would just find a decent high yield
savings account and uh you'll be good to
go there
congratulations what thanks what are
your thoughts on Treasury bonds like
should I stay away from that I would
stick with the high old savings account
cuz we're seeing the the very similar
rates without any restrictions uh for
taking the money out early and all of
that so I'm a fan of the highill saing
account right now for that temporary
parking
spot okay roll it all over that's
exciting you love taking that call well
you know we get a lot of you know crisis
situations this is a good problem to
have do I park half a million dollars
and nothing against our good friends in
Nevada but moving from the desert to the
Rockies oh different landscape it's a
very different deal speaking of the
Rockies Darcy is joining us somewhere
near Denver Colorado Darcy how can we
help hi George and Ken thank you so much
for taking my call you bet what's
up um so my husband and I um are really
stuck on baby step three where we're
losing money out of that fund like every
month we we can't seem to figure out
this uh budgeting thing but I think that
my husband should withdraw enough money
from our traditional
raw um to pay off our house how old is
he and he um he'll be 59 and a half next
October um but the backstory is is that
the house uh mortgage payment is 50% of
our income we both hate our jobs and I'm
probably about to be fired because the
state has filed a civil rights
discrimination case against my employer
o you got a lot going on
there yeah we got over a
million um I mean yeah I I can tell you
any numbers you want to know what's left
on the
mortgage I'm sorry what's left on the
mortgage what's the
balance
467,000 and what is your household
income right
now our household income
is
um about 7,000 take-home 7,000 take-home
okay and and what's in your nest egg in
all the retirement
accounts okay so our traditional Roth
has
$778,000
n the second Roth which is mine has
12,551 my husband has a 401k in his work
and that has about 880,000 in it he
wasn't totally sure um and I am an
educator so I'm under the state um perah
program and I have
54,7
121 okay great so we're close to a
million in our nest egg and you're
saying I want to Rob half of my entire
Nest Egg to pay off the
house well the house is worth at least
600,000 but it's half of our income it's
50% of our take-home I understand that
what I'm worried about is your house
doesn't produce any income and so you're
living in this house and now you have
less than $500,000 to live on for the
rest of your life am I
correct um well no because if we sell
the house we'll end up with 600,000 at
least okay but I'm saying I don't want
you to have to sell your house that you
love I want you to be able to retire
with dignity and not have to go oh we're
broke we have to sell the
house so while it's great you guys have
a great net worth I'm just looking
forward going is robbing this Roth a
year from now the best idea and it
sounds like you want to rob the Roth
earlier than next
October no I'll I'll wait but my H
husband is totally against it for he
says tax reasons but we're stuck on baby
step three and we just can't figure out
well it sounds like we got to stop
having life just happen to us and get
ahead of things and get better
maintenance on things and these
emergencies aren't going to keep hitting
you we're going to figure out the job
situation but right now I would not make
any big moves I would stay put and worse
comes to worse sounds like you might
need to sell your house but I would not
Rob your retirement instantaneously and
I get very serious very intentional to
get new gigs very soon this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues thrilled to
have you with us I'm Ken Coleman George
camel joins me 8825 5225 8825
5225 let's go to Phoenix Arizona Anthony
is on the line Anthony how can we help
hi there gentlemen good afternoon um so
I'm coming up on my first eligible
retirement date um I currently work in
public safety S have a def find pension
benefit um on that date coming up um I'm
kind of battling some a lot of
compassion fatigue as well as burnout in
my current job and wondering if I should
retire and try to pursue a second
passion and a second career um I love to
travel so being a travel agent or
something like that um our total
household debt right now is about
$20,000 not including our mortgage since
the interest rate is practically free at
this point Point um so when I if I were
to retire I'd walk away with my defined
benefit plus about an additional $3 to
$40,000 so I would be able I would have
the startup cost and I would we would be
debt-free going into it and I just don't
know if it's the smartest decision all
right so I can keep I can keep working
and the pension goes up and my the other
investment Nest EG accounts continue to
grow but I don't know yeah I think you
do I think you do my guess Anthony is is
your head and heart are in a wrestling
match and so that's why you called today
I think your head's telling you to stay
in the
guaranteed thing that you know that has
the pension and I think your heart's
telling you to
leave yeah but I I I guess I just don't
know which one to follow I guess I just
don't know which one to follow well just
confirm that I'm right I me I'm guessing
you're saying I'm right that that your
heart's telling you to leave yeah no I
mean I I I I I I love the job that I
have um but it's just one of those I
wake up every morning and everything's
great and I start to drive into work and
I'm like oh my god do I have the
emotional energy to do this one more day
what are you
doing I'm a homicide detective
oh
yeah um it's pretty it's a pretty heavy
job yeah I can't even begin to
comprehend that so I won't try but let
me ask this this is this is interesting
to me
if well let let me ask you this what
part do you love tell me the part about
being a detective that you
love oh giving solving the cases and
giving fam's closure
okay so it's the investigative part
tearing into it digging uh putting the
puzzle pieces together and then after
doing all that uh giving answers to the
family that's the part love the the part
that burns you out is just all the
trauma and all the disgusting stuff with
it correct yeah it's kind of the trauma
the disgusting stuff you know the the
fighting with the attorney fighting with
you know internal internal politics and
drama within the job I'm going to throw
something to be exhausting if you didn't
have to deal with that would you be
calling us about this issue if we took
the disgusting trauma and all the fight
but you were just doing the
investigative part to get to the bottom
of something to give some sense of
closure if we just kept it there would
you be calling
us I don't know I'm G to I'm G to say
that I don't think you would and I'm not
trying to talk you out of the travel
agent job I'm going to tell you to
pursue the travel agent thing on the
side okay but I want you before you walk
away I want you to take some time and
not a lot of time because I think you're
you're probably getting to your limit of
trauma and just junk I just wonder if
there's another role that involves the
investigative side the
puzzles uh the closure I just wonder if
there's not another role that way in in
in doing that work that doesn't involve
the trauma and I mean I'm I'm a little
bit limited here because I'm not in that
world but I think you know what I'm
talking about is that fair uh it is it
is I you know I I've spoken with the the
spouse about that to try to figure out
what that would look like there's not a
lot of um of appetite for anything that
would be more dangerous than no no no
but see but here's the deal I'm pushing
against that I I don't know that it has
to be dangerous I wonder if you were
like maybe investigating Financial
crimes or
investigating um I don't know I mean
maybe uh um uh insurance fraud or like
could you work for big insurance
companies I mean I'm really trying to
brainstorm here but I know there's more
out there that don't require you to be
CIA FBI and all that I I I'm just
telling you I think it's worth kicking
the tires do you understand what I'm
saying no I do because here's the deal
if we if we remove the trauma and the
danger and we and we we we are mostly
80% of our day in the investigation and
putting the puzzle pieces together and
giving
closure I man that could be really great
and it involves good retirement plans
401ks George all the investment piece I
I at least want to kick the tires and
but while I'm looking for that I'm also
going all right let me uh let me make
the moves and let's pay the debt off and
let's uh let's uh get the travel agent
thing going on the side because it's
going to take some time on the travel
agent thing to get the income up to
where you
are you do realize that oh no no
absolutely yeah I totally recognize that
um if I if I were to if I were to leave
um you know public service and law
enforcement you know I mean my my
take-home would be and my the difference
between my take-home now and my take-
home in retirement is zero I'm going to
be bringing home that the same so oh
anything I do above and beyond that is
extra okay so I'm still GNA hold to what
I'm saying I think you should kick the
tires see if I can find something that I
love yeah I like a related role that
maybe isn't as on the scene maybe behind
the scenes a little bit more but if you
can't find it you're not going backwards
financially and you get a chance to take
a shot at this so I I would just
consider that I'd also go talk to people
who are doing independent travel agent
work full-time and you know take him out
to dinner coffee and say hey how did you
get into it how did you get to where you
are today doing this fulltime and see if
it's something you'd like to do they
might be able to kick you some of the
smaller gigs and start to get a taste of
it and that's something you can
absolutely do on the side right now
versus Jumping Ship completely hoping
that it's going to work out maybe
Anthony could book The Camel Coleman
vacation now we're talking you got your
first client Anthony sounds great hey
man we appreciate it we just eat
something with a lot of shuffle board
activities George is really big in the
shuffle and put putt I've been known to
kick Ken's butt in some putt putt this
again you beat me one time because I
basically quit Austin you know and it's
still the greatest day of my life and
fact that your wife got to watch me
decimate you in mini golf is one of the
greatest Joys known to man I I wanted to
point out to the audience right now that
George a did win but he struggles with
proper uses of adjectives there was no
decimation going on you you snuck in
somehow because you hit it through the
elephant's mouth out the ear and it went
in the last hole something of that
nature it was Ken claims he was phoning
it in that day I promise you I was
phoning it in you and any competitive
Sports thing is phoning it in just by
nature of being there and I love you I'm
trying to get him out on the pickle ball
court folks America needs to see George
Campbell and Ken Coleman in a pickle
ball match I can tell you right now
we're getting a lot of bobbleheads out
in the audience there's a lot of things
America needs right now I don't think
you and I playing pickle ball is one of
them I disagree because there's a lot of
dark stuff going on in the world today
inflation's there people need to laugh
and I promise you if you and I played
pickle ball Live on YouTube Coleman C
charity tournament there we could raise
some money for something good at least a
100 bucks we need to get Rachel out
there delone uh Jade I'd ask Dave to get
out there but he's no chance he's you're
now involving people who have athletic
ability I'm out well I have athletic
ability you you forgot about that okay I
need a rematch I need a I need a rematch
so that I can gloat when I beat you in
pickle ball no I think I'm going to just
take my win and go
home I love it fantastic we are having a
good time uh Hey every dollar webinar I
got to mention that really quick George
tell folks why they need to be a part of
that yes we are we've been doing these
Rachel Jade warshan myself it's totally
free you can sign up at every doll.com
budgeting and for an hour we're going to
sit with you show you how to create
margin by using every dollar show you
the ins and outs of the product and
we've had great response thousands of
people show up on these virtual calls
you can watch the replay later if you
miss it and can't make the time so go
sign up regardless everydollar.com
budgeting we've got one coming up next
week just occurred to me I need to do a
pickle ball
webinar work on that hard pass you think
so all right we'll see I'm going to talk
to Dave about it this is the Ramy show
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsy show 88255 225 is the phone number
to jump in I'm Ken Coleman George
Campbell is with me and we are taking
your calls about your life your money
your work your relationships let's go to
Nathan who's on the line in Charleston
South Carolina Nathan how can we
help hey guys how you doing doing well
what's going
on um so me and my wife need a little
bit of guidance if you guys don't mind
so we are freshly married the last two
years we got married um and when we got
married we bought a house in our
hometown and uh I went in and I gut it
the entire thing and redid it and that
was back when the interest rates were
down the low twos and um we end up
gaining quite a bit of accurity in it we
got about 135,000 th000 in equity and uh
we actually F God calling us out of
there so we end up moving about 3 months
ago about eight hours away to South
Carolina um she she's in Ministry and uh
so I ended up renting my house out when
I moved we're currently renting down
here I've end up renting my house out
when I moved uh mainly because my
parents have six paid off rental homes
and that's basically all they do now
they're retired and they said they take
care of it um and it's bringing in good
money um but we are currently in about
$90,000 of student debt and I am
wondering if we should sell the home pay
off our student debt and kind of have a
good three to six month emergency at
that point we have about three months
saved up right now but that's kind of
where we're
at
okay um well my guess is you called on
the show you know what my answer is
going to
be sell the house yeah I that's great
that your parents are there as a you
know kind of the property management
crew but as it stands today if you're
living in Charleston would you go buy
this property as a
rental
no and the fact that you've got all the
debt on the other side and it sounded
like you were excited about it
propelling your financial future you
become completely debt-free with a fully
funded emergency fund with money left
over to start funding your next goal
which I assume is going to be being a
homeowner in
Charleston correct yeah we're looking to
do that maybe start a family so I'm just
thinking more about getting out of Deb
to better do that I know longterm one on
rent properties is kind what my parents
taught me but again they've paid off all
theirs so it makes a little bit of a
difference and guess what when you tell
your parents about this this they're
going to go oh my gosh don't listen to
those guy you should keep the rental
property we'll take care of it it's fine
you can put a little bit down on your
next house while you still have your
student loans you'll be okay is that
what they would say you
think yeah probably so they don't like
that either though so I don't know they
bought they bought the Ral homes and
cash as well they kind of run that same
game that's what's up well I'd take
after Mom and Dad then and go that's my
goal I want to become a homeowner I want
to pay my place off because you guys are
young how old are you
two uh 25 and 23 that's amazing so let's
fast forward right a year from now you
have no debt fully funded emergency fund
well on your way to saving up a down
payment
correct correct years save now too yeah
and then you'll have a house in
Charleston let's aggressively get that
thing paid off and then let's start
saving up for an investment property and
my guess is by the time you're in your
early 30s to mid-30s you're going to
have a paid for investment
property W that sounds like forever from
now but let me tell you man you got a
good 70 years left on this Earth you got
plenty of time Lord willing I really
appreciate it guys yeah yeah you bet
thank you for the call that's awesome
yeah love that uh how about your old
neck of the woods Mary's joining us in
Boston Massachusetts Mary how can we
help hi thank you for taking my call um
I'm 55 and I'm working full-time um I'd
like to know whether I should put my
money toward uh paying off my HELOC or
credit card bills and my credit card
bills are mostly for schooling um I'd
like to change careers eventually and so
I'm studying at the same time um my
credit card bills have zero interest for
a year and my HELOC is at 1.9% also for
a year and the HELOC is at um
95,000 and what about the student
loans excuse me how much do you have in
student loans
I don't have any student loans um it's
credit card bills so in the yeah on the
credit card how much is on there yeah 17
17 okay great and what's your
income I make about 97 a year okay I'm
focusing on these credit cards ASAP and
this HELOC we can put in we can put that
next what what's left on the
mortgage there's no mortgage just the
helck yes okay well that's that makes it
really easy I'm going to put all my
focus on this credit card at the 0% and
not because it's the interest rate but
because it's the smallest
debt
okay and making 97 you could pay this
off what in say two let's say another
six months on the credit
cards yes and then another two years to
get rid of the
HELOC uh yes that would be my plan well
that's what I'm nervous about is that
it's going to go to Prime afterward when
does the hilock go to
Prime and it'll go July of next year
2024 well you're not going to be able to
pay it off earlier than that anyways
right right so it sounds like we uh we
made a what we call a stupid tax is what
we're going to pay on this and we're
going to get rid of it super fast we're
going to get really aggressive about
this do you know what the rate might go
to at that
point no I'm guessing well right now
they're saying about seven point
whatever but who knows you will survive
it but uh you know you kind of touch the
hot stove and you go that didn't feel
good not doing the HELOC again right no
no and you got a great end up um yes I
ended up buying a house and it ended up
costing me it was next door to my
parents my my mother is sick so I ended
up paying more than I wanted to or else
I would have lost it um and I had to gut
the whole thing so that's really why you
know ended up costing me a little bit
more
but also I have about 20,000 in savings
I'm just kind of holding off for
emergency fund should I use any of that
to pay anything down or just keep I
would absolutely let's get rid of this
credit card debt today even sitting at
0% it's going to clear up the payment
you're going to be free to focus on that
HELOC and get this done even faster and
if an emergency comes up you're going to
pause these baby steps that we're
talking about and you're going to
aggressively attack whatever emergency
has come up sell stuff make more and
cover it and likely you're not going to
have a $10,000 emergency coming up it's
going to be those ankle biters those 200
bucks 500 bucks and so that's what I
would be focused on is just following
these baby steps through baby step 1,000
bucks baby step two all debt all
Consumer Debt gone using the debt
snowball
method okay great okay yeah we're
cheering you on
Mary okay great thank you so much yeah
thank for the call awesome stuff love
that I mean that's when when people get
that they they see the light bulb kind
of go off like uh oh I can actually do
this this is doable it's well there's so
many options and it can be overwhelming
and so just to have a filter you can lay
down and go okay I'm going to filter it
through this I want to get rid of the
debt the smallest one will get knocked
out the fastest I've got money in the
bank I could use the problem is dealing
with the fear of oh my gosh I'm going to
go down to $3,000 in savings and I
worked hard to get up to that 20 what's
the best way to overcome that I've heard
you we talk a lot but I'm just curious
you you've coached a lot of people now
what is the best way to overcome that
fear well number one they have to
realize the money has someone else's
name on it already it may be in your
account but when you owe someone $20,000
okay and you have $20,000 sitting in
savings you don't really have 20,000 in
savings your body is keeping the score
MH as the book says and therefore you're
not truly safe you have the illusion of
safety which is sometimes scarier cuz we
get lulled into a sense of comfort and
so part of getting over that fear is
seeing the freedom on the other side and
starting to paint that transformational
picture of here's what happens you got
no payments think about that how that
would feel think about what that does
for your budget and your finances and
how much faster you can tackle the next
debt that's what I found helps most
people get over that hump so are you
saying that there is a for lack of a
better word a chemical transformation
when you walk through those two
exercises that you just gave us the
perspective of it's really not my money
I owe it to somebody else and then once
I eliminate that debt and all those
feelings even though I only have two
grand or one grand left in my emergency
fund you're saying that stress is far
less the chemicals with that stress is
far less than what you're experiencing
to give you some Ken Coleman
alliteration I think it turns the fear
into fuel when you have a th000 bucks
you're like I'm not safe things are not
okay and I go yeah now you understand
what's really happening this is the
reality that your financial situation
has been and when you follow this Proven
Plan millions of people have done it so
this is not something that has a lot of
risk involved turn your fear into fuel I
love the alliteration it's another
pencil drop or as we say here what is it
a cancel
drop is that good Austin's rolling his
eyes I'll have to go check on him in the
booth don't fear more puns up next and
your calls this is the Ramsey
[Music]
shot
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel the
phone number is
88255 225 our scripture of the day comes
from Proverbs 13 verse 20 walk with the
wise and become wise for a companion of
fools suffers harm and our quote today
from Thomas Soul four words today in the
quote Thomas doesn't need a lot of words
to drop the depth that's it intellect is
not wisdom oo you got to sit there and
think about that one for a moment well
it takes intellect to understand it it
well intellect is not not wisdom in
other words which kind of is wisdom in
in and of itself it's kind of wisdom it
is knowledge is overrated it's pretty
meta and all you got to do is hang out
on uh on Ivy League campuses to I
thought you were GNA say Twitter Twitter
would be the opposite Twitter is any
fool can type that's what my big quote
about Twitter would be y just okay I'm
going to fire off some opinion doesn't
matter if it's honest doesn't matter if
it's right just there we go it feels
good to get it outs
Alexander is up next in Orlando Florida
Alexander how can we
help hi uh
big big fan of the show hey hey thank
you how can we help so um I'm 18 I'm 22
years old my apologies and I just got a
unarmed security job which pays $18 per
hour a full-time and I get paid weekly
and
um I have a bit of a dilemma because and
there's unlimited overtime when it comes
to that job less I'd say 2021 my parents
which I am grateful for gifted me a 2018
mercedesbenz and they were going to take
care of all of it and you know I was
just grateful for it like who wouldn't
be and so their business within the last
year I'd say kind of went down
drastically to where they're basically
in survival mode and they had put the
payments on me me so I'm trying to see
how I could possibly get that done
because the payments per monthly on the
car note is 600 they paid uh
29,000 in total for the vehicle they
financed it actually and there's 20,000
left uh I have unfortunately nothing in
savings and I looked at the lowest
possible way for any type of car
insurance on this vehicle the lowest I
could find is 450 and I have a clean
record not even a parking ticket so
basically paying um well you're an
18-year- old so the car insurance is
through the roof for young drivers oh no
oh no I'm 22 oh you're 22 now okay and
what what are you making with your
job uh 18 per hour plus unlimited
overtime okay so you're making about 36
Grand a year yeah without
overtime yeah and what's the car
worth oh the car is worth uh I'd say 21
to 20,000 okay that's a lot of car for
for a guy making
18 well you're and you're saying Hey how
do I do you want to get out of this well
his parents transfer the payments to him
so you're stuck with this
thing yeah unless you sell
it that's the thing um we actually don't
have the title it's in my father's name
but the financing company they have the
title until we're able to pay off the uh
vehicle so I don't think we could sell
it or is it no who whoa whoa whoa whoa
of course you can sell it um if your dad
if your dad has has basically said you
need take over the payments of this he
needs to sign the title over to you
that's pretty
simple but but the point is somebody
sells the car it doesn't here here
here's the point we're making this too
complicated Alexander here's what
happens you list the car today and you
sell the car and you can do the
transaction at the lender's office where
they'll give you the title as soon as
it's paid off that's right once the
person buys the car you know yeah just
this is all simple stuff but you don't
you don't you're I don't even know how
to explain this this is so simple just
sell the car and then the title will be
transferred to the person who buys the
car okay so just get a hold of the
company the lending company and
basically find a buyer yes but you do it
all simultaneously so the transaction
happens they'll then release the title
once the car is paid off and then you
can transfer the title you're going to
need your dad there cuz you said it's in
his name
still yeah but sell the car you're not
going to sell this to dealer you're
going to sell it private sale do you
understand what we're saying private
sale can I get more description on that
please yes so you listed on Facebook
Marketplace or you listed on Craigslist
or you listed on AutoTrader or yeah
because the dealer is going to give you
much much less for it because they're in
the business of making a profit that's
right so if you're saying the car is
worth you said it's worth how much 21 20
to 21,000 okay so the dealer's going to
go hey we'll give you 14 for it right we
don't want that and what do you owe on
the car
again uh 20 yeah 20,000 okay so let's
just keep it simple just for explaining
to you what you're going to do if the
car if the Bluebook and you need to go
to kellybluebook.com and put in the VIN
number and it'll get you a really
accurate number let's just say that you
sell it for 20 you owe 20 okay so you
sell it to a person they give you 20,000
you pay the car off the finance company
gives you the title you sign the title
over those people that's how it works
very simple your dad can be involved
with the whole thing but you need to get
rid of this car and you need to get rid
of it before it continues to depreciate
because you don't want to be upside down
you're right at that break now which you
need some money to get a different car
as well right yeah that's the thing yeah
so how quickly can you save up and get a
beater
car oh how much you thinking
5,000 5,000 uh might take a couple
months yeah okay so in a couple months
we can sell this car it's not going to
depreciate that much in a couple months
right and as soon as that car is sold
you got the other one right there ready
to go and that insurance is also going
to be a whole lot cheaper and you're
going to do it with cash so don't go to
a dealership and say I have $5,000
they'll say hey well we can get your
payments nice and low buddy uhuh we're
going to pay cash you're going to buy
this car from a Facebook Marketplace an
independent used car dealership and it's
not going to be a pretty car it's not
going to be your beautiful Mercedes
you've been driving yeah so get ready
emotionally
yeah but what you're going to also do is
get an inspection on it it'll cost you a
hundred bucks you can take it to a
firestone and get it inspected make sure
you're not buying you know a lemon of a
car and take it for a test drive do your
due diligence and that should get you at
least out of this pickle do you have any
other
debt oh no okay great and then let's
start to use this income to build
ourselves an emergency fund once we get
out of this car
debacle all right perfect hope that that
helps man sorry you're dealing with that
and parents that are listening out there
please don't gift your kids debt yeah I
mean wow don't call it a gift he doesn't
even understand and unfortunately they
haven't even told him look here are your
options if you want to sell it I'll walk
you through it you he doesn't even know
and so not just gifting them debt but
yeah I want to know do they did they
when he says transfer the payments is it
actual do they actually legally transfer
the loan or they just said hey you're
sign in and you pay this now you do that
if the dad's name is still on the title
I don't know if the finance company
would do that would change the loan to
this maybe they would poor 22-year-old
who's now stuck with it yeah cuz I don't
think they would have let let him
finance that car yeah man and now that I
think about it uh and I know he's on
hold I hope you can still hear us
Alexander but I maybe $30,000 car I mean
a beater I mean $5,000 car is not a
beater well these days it used to be the
Thousand car now with how crazy the car
market is you know you're looking at
four or 5,000 bucks for the bottom of
the barrel Vehicles yeah that's still
run yeah I mean but he's got to do what
he's got to do he may be working a
little crazy hours he might be taking
some Ubers yeah now he's driving an uh
you know the unarmored truck it sounds
like doing unarmed security I don't know
if that comes with a vehicle or not
sometimes you'll have a vehicle for that
you could drive home yeah that's an
option too interesting man well it's
been a fun Show Ken it has been I I
thought you were getting ready to say
something I was well I want to let
people know we've got our money in
marriage getaway coming up yeah Corner
through the 21st and I'm going to be
speaking you've been added to the uh
docket what are you going to be speaking
on uh my talk is called Pillow Talk the
dirty secrets of budgeting really if
you're going to do a budgeting talk make
it spicy at a couple's event I got to
tell you I when I asked you it was out
of courtesy now I'm interested now he's
in it was a courtesy ask to set up the
event but then when you said the title
of the talk was pillow talk I want to
see the illustrations well the goal is
to let couples have fun but also get
equipped with tools cast a vision create
a life you're not suggesting that people
talk about the budget in bed are you no
it's about throw pillows there's my
teaser so ramsy solutions.com events
there's still some spots left Rachel
Cruz Dr jalone uh Jade warshaw and
myself will be there all weekend October
19th through the 21st all right good
stuff George Campell always fun to be
with you want to say a big thanks to
Austin and all of the kind folks in the
booth that keep us on the air and to you
America and to the folks in the lobby
thank you so much for listening and
watching this is the ramsy
show
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsey bab steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started